[Music]
how do I stop grieving somebody that's
alive it's my dad he was uh he was a
Bard back when I was 14 he's alive and I
can see him you know once a year and I
know some people don't even get that so
I'm grateful no no no no no hey hold on
don't compare your grief to somebody
[Music]
else what in the world is going on this
is John with the Dr John deloney
show so grateful that you've joined us I
know um the one thing that many of us
don't have is time we don't have a lot
of time and you're choosing to spend an
hour with me today and I'm really
grateful um on the show as you know we
talk about relationships we talk about
mental health emotional health
whatever's going on in your life
school's starting your kids are doing
Wild Things uh you're falling out of
love with somebody that you care about
whatever's going on in your world my
promise is I'll tell you the truth and
I'll sit with you in the mess and we
will figure out what the next step is if
you want to be on the show show give me
a buzz at 84469
33291 or go to John
del.
askk um don't forget I know I'm just
like beating this drum to death as
though I'm like a slipnot drummer my new
book building a non- anxious
life a book not about how
to deal with a panic attack there's that
book's been written not a book on how to
like when I'm at the mall and I feel at
the mall that's the oldest sentence ever
when I met the mall on my phone calling
Blockbuster right are you listening to
like Tiffany all that's happening
running just as fast as we can can can
yeah no not when you're at the mall but
when you're in an anxious moment this
book's not for you that book has been
written there's some great books out
there by Dr Wendy Suzuki DR Jud Brewer
theyve written some great books on that
this book is stepping back and saying
hey why don't why am I always stressed
why am I always completely burned out
when I look around why are my
relationships all either either on fire
or they're in
Ash how do I back out of this thing and
do something different this book is
called building a non- anxious life and
it's about changing for some of us it's
about changing one or two important
things for some of us it's about
changing everything and what's different
in this book is then my last one is this
gives you a map it gives you a road map
to follow for you for you and your
partner for you and your kids whatever's
going on how do we build a non-anxious
life let's reverse engineer this world
we want to inhabit
and then the alarms do they just quit
ringing or they only ring when they need
to and that's that's important go to
john.com and check that out all right
let's run out to Indianapolis and talk
to allora that's probably the radest
name of anyone on the show ever what's
up
allora hey what's up is that hey what's
up is is your name allora really yes
dude what a beautiful beautiful name
that's awesome all right so what's up
how can I
help so my first like main question
question is how do I get my husband to
see that you know being a stay-at-home
mom isn't just an easy task of doing
just simple
things what's your secondary
question um how do I get him to treat me
more like a wife and not just someone to
communicate with when he wants
sex that is the
question so anytime somebody asked me
how do I get my husband
to um see me as a stay-at-home mom or
someone who's working part-time and
we've got three kids or whatever
um I'm going to walk through like The
Temptations here and then we'll get to
your question is that cool use this as
like a moment to teach a little bit um
so like one one idea is you can just go
out of town for a week and just let him
like stay at home and figure it out
right that happened to me early on we
only had one kid and by day two I didn't
know what day it was I didn't know what
time it was like everything was just
everywhere and um there was like Taco
Bell rappers growing out of the coffee
table and stuff it was just chaos um so
that's the Temptation number one right
is I'll show you I'll prove it to you
Temptation number two is um I'm going to
make you a minute by minute I'm going to
make you like a list of my things I do
every day and we're going to compare
lists you what you do at work versus
what what I do here um and we're going
to do that that's also a Temptation I
don't think that's effective here
because what you're talking about is
honor and dignity and trust it is not
about
um uh strategy and calendar preparation
okay and your second question is the
most important one and I think your
first question about how do I convince
my husband that what I'm doing is
actually
hard man that's way distant second
question to how do I get my husband to
treat me like a human
being yeah when did that
start it's been since our daughter
was born before that things were great
but after that he just kind of you know
threw me to the side if he wants sex
he'll communicate otherwise it's I'll
ask him what he wants for dinner and
it's I don't care or you know he won't
talk to me in person either it's always
through like Facebook Messenger or
through text like there's no actual
communication between
us okay two important things here number
one on one area I don't fully believe
you okay and know that I'm on your team
okay yeah but this is it's very very
rare that somebody flips a switch like
this he's probably been a jerk for a
long time is that fair or no yeah yeah
yeah before kid before
baby yeah
yeah so why' you end up with
him I it was basically through being
hurt not having a dad growing up and you
know
just I was on the verge of leaving him
before our daughter was born but when I
found out I was pregnant I was like I
don't want my child to grow up without
her dad like I did your daughter is
growing up without her dad he just
happens to live in the same
house your daughter's also getting a
ringside seat into how a terrible human
being treats a
woman a woman that he stood before his
friends and his family and God and said
I do
forever and I'm not surprising you
though I mean you know this right yeah
so you said you grew up without a dad
was was growing up
hard yeah I was adopted so I was
basically raised in a family with
medically Fragile Kids I was the only
one normal you know so I was kind of
just left myself okay most of my
life how old are
you
24 so we're gonna have a real scary
conversation is that okay yeah CU I know
you've thought this through and my
promise is I'm going to be honest okay
this is the part when people listening
to the
show start yelling just leave him what
are you doing why don't you just move
out
right yeah and that's the moment when
the 24 year-old
mom who's been a stay-at-home mom who's
been beating down her entire
life says yeah but how do I eat and how
do I pay rent where am I going to
go yeah so my question for you is where
would you
go probably back to New Mexico where my
family is is that a safe place to go for
a season to get your feet underneath
you yes and no I mean I'm still kind of
beat down by that side of my family I
always have been because I wasn't the
you know the girly girl or the girl that
went and got a degree in nursing to them
like the rest of my family was or you
know you do have a degree in nursing or
you didn't get one I didn't both my
sisters and my mom did okay all right so
you're taking a different path and when
you take a different path a it looks
cool on Instagram and B in real life
taking your own path is hard right it's
just harder and that's cool it's just
it's just more of a struggle um
I'm going a go as far to say based on
what you're telling me about him you are
not in a safe position is that fair
you're home safe
yeah my home is safe yes other than you
know the the fact that you live with a
grizzly bear who won't talk to
you yeah so let me flip this around have
you sat down and talked to him and said
hey what
happened I've tried to and he just says
you know basically that I'm making him
sound like a
monster he is a monster
Laura I mean tell me I'm wrong defend
him if he's worth
defending
no are you done with
this yeah you sound done and you know
one of my policies on the show is I
never tell somebody to get divorced
unless they're at uh in in phys
physically or psychologically
unsafe um so I can't make that call for
you but I do think it's really really
important that you get with a
professional counselor ASAP to do a
couple of things number one you have to
learn how to stand up on your own two
feet and you
can and I think you've got those skills
because you had to do that growing up in
a house where you were an invisible kid
and
also it's scary right especially being a
single
mom two you're going to have to get some
wisdom and guidance on how to navigate
this relationship whether you try to
save it again or you end up ending it
you're going to need somebody to walk
alongside you
okay okay I also know that stuff costs
money so I'm going to give you three
months with my friends at betterhelp for
free okay okay and but you got to
promise me that you'll use it yeah I
will and that might only be a bridge to
get you to a counselor in town okay and
um but you got to promise that you're
going to do it and it can be weekly
counseling that you can do via your
phone you can do on on um the computer
right on Zoom or whatever however you
want to set it up but you got to promise
me that you'll do it will you yeah yes
okay another thing I'm going to send you
for your home I'm going to send you um
Financial Peace University in the every
dollar app for a year here's why I'm
doing that two things number one I've
seen it happen over and over and over
again that talking about budgets forces
couples to sit at a
table sitting at a table may not be safe
for you and that's okay if it's not but
talking about money means you have to
talk about what are our values and what
do we want to do and what are our dreams
and what kind of house do we want to
live in what kind of home do we want to
have what kind of vacations do we want
to go on it forces you to have those
conversations about values and goals and
unification or parts where you're like
I'm out you have to come to the table on
that and my little end around here is
also it's going to give you some skills
that you don't have about managing money
making money how insurance and all that
stuff works that you probably aren't
aren't up to up to up to skill on but
it's going to give you some insights
into what life would be like if you end
up going back to New Mexico for a season
okay okay so hang on I'm going to send
all that stuff to you in all I need you
to hear me walk away with this number
one you're not
crazy you're not
crazy it is I I don't blame any guy who
just got married who's working really
hard and he gets home because this
happened to me I'd get home from work
and my wife would just hand me our kit
and she by the way she was working
full-time so that just shows you what an
ignorant I was but she would just
hand me the kid and my first thought was
whoa I just got home from work you know
how tired I am that would be my first
thought that's just me being honest and
I learned over in short order oh my
fatigue is pretend fatigue compared to
what she's working through right it's
not real it actually super was real but
it was we had to figure it out right so
I'm not ever going to fault a guy for
being like what do you do all day that's
a that's an honest question that if we
don't ask that question then what
happens is you end up being quiet about
it you end up getting building up
resentment and that's stupid and
that is different that's a different
question to hey what happens here all
day is different
than I don't talk to my wife I just talk
to her on Facebook Messenger like a
child I only contact her when I want sex
I don't interact with my CH with my new
baby that has nothing to do with how do
I convince my husband that I've got
value that I'm doing stuff during the
day I say this often on the show and
I'll I'll end the call with
this behavior is a
language so often we try to get people
to talk to us and they don't talk they
don't have the communication they the
ability to talk we we we like hey will
you sit down and talk to me you sit down
and talk to me and really through their
actions they've been loud and
clear and in a situation like this I can
ask like hey I want to talk to that guy
see if your marriage is over or behavior
is a language he is being very clear he
has no interest in being married to her
he's interested in having someone to
sleep with every once in a while he's
interested in having uh a a living
housekeeper he is not interested in
being married or having a wife doing
life with somebody behavior is a
language I hate this for you allur we'll
be with you every step of the way call
anytime um please please reach out to my
friends at better help um I got you for
3 months please reach out to them um
you're going to need somebody in your
corner cor cuz it's going to be a long
scary road but you got this we'll be
right
back good folks slowing down is a
critical aspect of mental health calming
music prayers meditation they're all
great ways to find peace and hallow
makes it easy to start a daily practice
of meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice prayer meditate and build a
deeper more meaningful spiritual life
and ReDiscover true peace go to hall.com
dealone toay to get three months of
hallow for free hall.com
delone all right we're back let's go out
to Portland Oregon and talk to Jose
what's up
Jose how you doing I'm good
Kostas bi bian thank you for taking my
call you bet you man how can I help
brother yeah so my question is
um you're good man take a minute take a
minute how do how do I stop grieving
somebody that's
alive oh man that's a heavy
one tell me about it
so basically it's
uh it's my dad he was uh he was orted
back when I was 14
so about 14 years ago and jeez man
um yeah man I've had a lot of things
happen you know from that point on and
you know I'm I'm 29 now and um basically
have decided that it's time to work on
my um depression
so you know he's in Mexico and um I
talked to him you know weekly or but
it's been like this for so many years
that our conversations are like a minute
long and um I only see him maybe once a
year if that um so he's part of my life
but at the same time he's not
because
um because he's not in my life anymore
you know yeah and so does he does he
want to be does he like the phone calls
or they getting
awkward they're just I mean it's just so
short it's like hey how are you doing
good yeah um what are you doing going to
work okay talk to you tomorrow yeah and
so I just feel like
and know I mean he's alive and I can see
him you know once a year and I know some
people don't even get that so I'm
grateful no no no no no no hey hold on
don't compare your grief to somebody
else here's why that 14-year-old little
boy needed his dad and he got ripped
out and that 15year old boy and that 18y
old boy and that 25y old boy and I'm
telling you I'm in my 40s and I still
need my old
man okay there's no apologizing for that
brother that's your
dad and when you say I need to work on
my depression I get the sentiment but I
want you to be careful about that
language because that suggests like I
need to work on my engine of my car CU
my car is
broken your depression brother comes
naturally because your father got taken
from your home when you were 14 years
old and so your body shut the system
down so that the thing would keep
operating right it's like when your car
overheats it will turn itself off
sometimes right and so you're not broken
man your body's been trying to survive
without the Padre for a long
time are you a dad now yeah how old is
your
kids uh they're four and three okay I
the reason I asked that is I was
expecting there you'd have young kids
here's why
as
you if you're like me dude when you had
kid number one it was kind of a
whirlwind you had kid number two you
start to feel your heart expand in a way
that you didn't know was
possible and you realize the capacity
for love that you didn't know was
humanly capable especially within your
knuckleheaded chest right and then you
start to think oh my dad felt that
too and then there's this it's it's like
when you get older you feel this
different compassion for your parent
parents because you realized they were
hurting too and they wanted to do it
right and they messed up too and they
didn't know what day it was either and
the whole thing just gets Messier and
Messier and bigger this is called wisdom
and it's called forgiveness and it's
called just expand you're just going
through a natural moment in your life
and if your dad was with you it's when
you start being like all right he just
runs his mouth about politics that's
fine but we're gonna go get tacos anyway
he just runs his mouth about whatever
we're gonna go I'm gonna take him out to
dinner anyway because you have a
different level of compassion challenge
you have is you can't see
him when you say you get to see him once
a year do you go home to Mexico to see
him right yeah how are those
trips I mean it's it's they're quick
short I mean it's expensive I can only
take the one of the kids so it's
just it's like it's it's a lot to go see
him basically like I have to go through
a lot to get down there so it's not like
it's just quick and short it's like over
the weekend or you know maybe three days
and then you know I'm back home so it's
it's difficult basically
and you know I the last I took my
daughter um cuz he you know she's two
years old and he hadn't he hadn't even
seen her
and you know she does she doesn't know
him so she you know didn't want to be
around him you know she didn't want to
and yeah he just some old strange man
yeah right and so it's just I don't know
it's just and like I know when I try to
talk about the kids I I feel like he
just uh I feel like he shs down so and
I'll tell you this brother he has to it
doesn't surprise me at all I say that he
doesn't have to that's not fair he
doesn't have
to but he lost his son 14 years
ago right and it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't compute that he would
open up his heart again for the chance
to get hurt that bad
again it also isn't an excuse
right like he's he's Granddad he I mean
that's his job is to open up his heart
humongous and let these little grandkids
Swan Dive into it but I get that it's
hard
right I get that it's not not not an
excuse but it's a context right so here
here's I can give you a couple of nuts
and bolts man but I think there's a a a
a a 30,000 foot view of this that we
need to take but first
um I think you don't Grieve Your Dad I
think you grieve the picture of what you
wanted it to
be because your dad's still
there it's awkward it's weird those
phone calls are kind of
perun and in a weird way he doesn't know
you like he could have because he hasn't
seen you for he hasn't like hung out
with you and been like had a paternal
role in your life for 15 years right so
I get there's some awkwardness there um
so what we're grieving is not Dad dad's
there we're grieving this picture that
Fathers and Sons are supposed to be able
to hang out together and have dinner
together and bicker and complain with
one another and challenge each other to
arm wrestling matches and debate
politics and roll their eyes that you
know that's you're supposed to be able
to do that
that's what I'm
grieving that I lost all that all that
got ripped
away and then when I grieve that then I
can be about okay what's given the the
the reality that I live in I'm going to
choose to live in reality what can I
make of this this season and that looks
like this what I'm going to tell you is
going to sound
silly but I've seen it work over and
over and it's pretty magical if you kept
a small little log keep it on your phone
in the notes app on your phone but if
you kept just a series of questions that
when your kid does a
thing like why do you do that or what do
you think about this or you see
something about Mexico on the news and
you're like I wonder what if you kept a
list of
that and every time you talk to your dad
there was some intention to that phone
call not just a like we're punching our
card like phone call made phone call
answered goodbye instead of that but it
was like Dad my kid keeps doing do you
have any wisdom for
me dads struggle so much with feeling
like why don't people like
me and for you to reach out and say hey
what do you think about this I don't
know a dad in the world that doesn't
love giving wisdom they often give it
when it's not even asked for but if a
kid comes and asks his dad hey what do
you think God that's just like a gift
and so do you need that wisdom probably
not probably not but man a you'll give
you're you're you're putting oil in the
engine of that
relationship you're giving him something
to think about between
calls he may go look up something he may
go have some conversations at home and
this is not going to be the conversation
that I mean the relationship that you
wanted the one where you hug him and
youall have dinner together once a week
but it is going to be a different
version of what you have
now and maybe down the road you say hey
can you do FaceTime with me I want to
see your
face and it might be completely new
maybe I've done that maybe you haven't
but it's you being vulnerable and he
might say no it's too hard for him okay
so I actually have been thinking about
asking him you know just questions like
that
but and I don't know I guess I just hold
back just because and I feel like he's
just going to shut down if he might gets
personal he might but also
this if you reach out and say hey 14
years ago you got ripped from my life I
miss you and now I've got my own kids
and I need you and I know it's hard and
maybe you write this in a letter and
send it to
him but I'm entering into a season where
I need my dad I've needed my dad for 14
years but I really need him now I need a
partner in this and we can't see each
other all the time I don't have the
money to come down all the time
whatever but can we can I can I ask you
some questions on the phone can we talk
can we connect in that way can I will be
FaceTime with me once every two weeks
and dude dads are awkward on the phone
I'm the worst I'm awkward on the phone
my kids don't like talking to me on the
phone they're just like all right Dad
like because I it just is I I wish I
could be adventurous on the phone but
I'm not um so I wouldn't expect this to
just feel like a warm hug because it's
not it's a cheap substitute but at least
it's a
substitute and then I think longterm the
30,000 foot view I was talking about is
you have to ask yourself over
time how do I reverse engineer the life
I want versus the one I'm
living what does that mean is Portland
Oregon the place for us long term or can
I move South and be
closer to the Border closer to home is
that possible is there another job I
could take is there u a different
training I could get over time so that I
can potentially reconnect our
families you might not want to do that I
packed up and moved a thousand miles
away from my family right so that
doesn't not out of anger or anything but
it it isn't always practical that isn't
always the solution for everything but
at least it's you asking the broader
question how valuable is this
relationship to me what do I need to do
to bring it closer given the reality
that we're in he's not allowed back in
the
States and on and on that way and but
you begin to take some ownership of it
and then when you decide no Portland
organ a place for my family it's where
We've Got Roots it's where my wife is
from it's where my job is all that this
is where we are then you're owning
reality you're choosing to be where you
are and there's some peace to that still
hurts but there's some peace to that it
doesn't feel like you are being jerked
around by the government that took your
dad Away by the politicians over here by
the economics over here I make some
choices I'm choosing to live here I'm
choosing that and so part of this is
about gaining ownership back that's hard
to do man all I that to say I don't know
that you Grieve Your Dad
here I think you grieve the situation I
think you grieve the picture of what
should have been a Granddad with his two
little grandkids just sitting on the
front porch in a rocket chair being fat
being loud complaining about
stuff and he's not he's thousands of
miles
away that hurts
man and then I think you reach out you
write that letter to dad and say it's
been 14 years years and I need you are
you
in that's a scary letter to write
brother but I think he's worth it I
think you're worth it and I think your
kids having a Granddad it's worth it
too thank you for the call my man we'll
be right
back this show is sponsored by better
help hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connects you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become better help is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get match with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com dealone today to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right we're back let's go out
to Orlando Florida and talk to Mary
what's up
Mary hi good morning it's an honor to
speak with you the honor is all mine
what's up well um I have kind of a tough
question um so should and if so how can
I be a friend to someone who is
willingly staying in an abusive marriage
to a sexual
predator one that has intentionally hurt
some of our mutual friends do I lean in
or do I lean out
question that's a good one
um it's a good one but I think it's a
fairly simple answer tell me what you're
struggling with sure so I'm part of a
tight-nit group of friends um a year ago
we were all on vacation together with
our
families one of the husbands cornered
one of the single moms in the group um
and exposed himself to her and then
several other women of the group
admitted that he had also been touching
them inappropriately that day but they
were like so shocked and scared they
didn't know what to do immediately sure
um so this all happened while his wife
was in the Next Room usually taking care
of the
baby and then um so he was kicked out
immediately um and then it turns out
this wasn't an isolated event so yeah
this never happens like Tada it never
works like that right yes yeah well it's
it it was shocking to the rest of us but
like of course it's like you know um so
a separate victim decided to come
forward after that someone completely
separate and then so ultimately his wife
decided to stay with him and try and
make the marriage work did did the did
your friends uh press charges see in
jail so she attempted to the the problem
was there was like you know because
there wasn't any
physical they weren't children it was
his his word against hers they just
decided to not pick it up so the da
rejected it yeah well played da well
played idiot disappointing all right so
on to the next okay so then something
else happened yeah so several months
later he did it again this time to
someone they
employed another single mom we know um
and again his wife decided to stay so
she press charges so that's yes she
attempted to as well and they rejected
it again
so there's multiple report do you know
somebody at the DA's
office I you'd be amazed I called the
DA's office I'm not joking every single
day for weeks good for you every single
day good for you um but they have bigger
fish to fry I guess no they their their
job is to get sexual predators off
because this escalates this Behavior
doesn't stay static this Behavior mov
moves and it goes from exposure to
touching like it did in that house and I
promise you there's a wake of women this
has happened to that like you said you
said it perfectly it's so shocking that
this happens when your buddy's like
right next door and her husband's right
here that it shuts your body down in a
way that's unnerving you think like I
would never shut me down it does it just
shuts you down man and it's it's it's m
jeez Louise no this is their job this is
the fish that they need to be frying but
okay AG so tell me what you're
struggling with well because you know I
feel like she's being man his wife right
I feel like she's being manipulated and
emotionally abused by him I feel like
she is I feel like she is opting out of
your Friendship
Circle yeah
period and you can get inside her head
and try to insert yourself into her
marriage into what's going on behind
closed doors she knows she knows or or
here's the other thing
she is calling her best friends in the
world complete and utter
Liars oh no she knows it's true he he
admits it yeah then good God Almighty
then yes yeah I mean he just tells her
like oh I'll never do it again she she's
opted out she has opted out here's why
um if somebody's struggling with
addiction I have some counterintuitive
um I tend to think uh addiction is a
connection Disorder so my friends who
struggle with with addiction I I lean in
I don't give them money unless we're
working towards a specific thing um I
don't like it's not willy-nilly but I
lean into that okay um when somebody is
with a sexual predator someone's unsafe
someone's gonna going to enact violence
in our community they're out they have
opted out like I said earlier behavior
is a language they are choosing to leave
and I would tell her we no longer are
speak for yourself I no longer can be in
relationship with you connected to this
guy yeah and you get to draw that
boundary and she gets to say oh my gosh
you're abandoning me you're the worst he
said it would never happen blah great
cool whenever you put up a boundary the
people who you are putting up the
boundary against will come bang on that
boundary as hard as they can to see if
it will
hold yeah and as for me in my house I
don't hang out with sexual predators oh
for sure yeah I mean I don't you know
what I mean yeah I I think my heart's
just broken it that that to me sounds
more realistic I don't think I'm telling
you anything you don't
know I think it's just living with the
fact that like this is my best friend
and this well I have this conflict
because I have this foundational
principle that I do not let my friends
do hard things
alone and
so I'm okay but let me tell you where
that falls in on itself yeah she didn't
ask
you and so I don't let my friends do
hard things alone if they ask me yeah
but I can't insert myself into their
life if they clearly don't want me
there that's true and so what you're
trying to do is play God in her house
and she's saying I'm good yes and so
what you have to do is take control of
your
life and that sucks that's so
heartbreaking you said it best I love
heartbreak that's the greatest word for
it yeah because your friend doesn't want
your help she doesn't want your wisdom
she doesn't want your advice she doesn't
doesn't want anything to do with it she
wants to go on and pretend that
everything's great and I just have a
little rapy husband but it's okay yeah
horrible I feel terrible for their child
I feel terrible for everybody involved
I'm disgusted by the police response one
fine he said she said fine five people
in the same house over the same weekend
gets real sketchy then the next person a
few weeks later says hey this happened
too nah now I'm losing faith in you mhm
can I have a do I you have time for a
follow-up question yeah follow up bring
it so one thing I'm just really hitting
my head against is this perspective that
she has that like he has no control over
this because he's a sexual adct bull
crap on a stick on a pony in a box out
on the beach somewhere that's not true
great thank you absolutely not I have no
problem keeping my pants on so you know
I don't get it but it's just you know um
here's the deal I I know I know I've sat
with people who struggle with all sorts
of forms of sexual addiction it
happens I will even go as far to say
especially initially the impulse is very
hard to control it's real the the the
kind of like uh you have to sneeze and
you can't sneeze or I've I got diagnosed
with OCD long ago like I need to Blink
or I start counting things it's hard
when I catch myself and I have to stop
okay that's hard I feel it's almost like
a pressure that builds up
um and that is no excuse to destroy the
lives of other people so it becomes your
job if that's your impulse to go get the
care and help you need so you stop
hurting community members and if you
won't it's the police's job it's our
community's job to say you you have
exited out of our community you are no
longer allowed to be a part of this
community because you keep violating
people's sexual
boundaries that's how that goes and so I
will go with her as far as he can't
control the impulse it's a it's a it's
internal and that's where that ends
because he can control his behavior
period he can go get help period he can
say I won't be around any other people
until I get this under control period he
can go check himself into a
rehabilitation Clinic period and he's
choosing not to he's choosing to let
everybody else in his community all
these other women um who are a part of
his life through his wife through his
being on his child um they get to pay
the price for his cowardice and his his
unwillingness to go get
well
period I don't know if I made myself
clear enough on on that or not I I I
have I have so little patience for
sexual predating I Predators I I um in
several of my mentors like my professors
um wh were were Li are licensed in
working with behavioral sex um folks who
struggle with sexual behavior disorders
okay like and so I get it it's hard it's
a nightmare and it is not
permission I I mean I can't imagine
walking into a room of my wife's friends
and thinking you know what I really feel
like doing right now is taking my pants
off like I can imagine that I I
sympathize with somebody who that's
that's their body is like do it do it do
it and you can't do that you got to go
get help well and it's also very
predatory behavior of like who he
chooses of course it is yeah of course
it is and there's a real big Power Play
to do that when your wife's in the Next
Room like what are you GNA do time she's
in the house every time oh you're gonna
blow the weekend up you're going to make
a big deal in front of
her and your body goes just shut down
and then that power I
win I got it right I'm not having that
dude no way no way but I I I want to
honor you this is hard because you're
losing your good friend I also have to
say I don't talk crap about your friend
but I'm going going to um at this point
she has to begin to shoulder
this she's choosing to bring a sexual
predator into these
situations she's choosing to make
excuses for a sexual predator and that
makes her complicit
that makes you're a part of
it yeah that's my struggle
yeah I found out some hard things about
a friend of mine recently um not
anything like this um and it messed me
up messed me up they just weren't who I
thought they were and um nothing illegal
or anything like that but they weren't
who I thought they were and it it hurt
man I had just sit with that I think I
try to make excuses like I'm trying to
stop stop yeah because what happens when
you do that you compromise
you and then that leads to that one
moment when she's like I know he's had I
know he promised he won't do it but I
need him here at this thing is that cool
and you're like fine and then happens
again that's how that
happens so this is the season when you
grieve at like mad weep cry be angry be
frustrated
and then I think you have to go do the
right thing and I I applaud you for
calling the DA's office I think you
continue to Bang the Drum as loud as
possible all the time all the time all
the time Reach Out Reach Out Reach Out
reach out you hear any inkling that's
happened again calling everybody any
inkling that's happened again I'm
calling
everybody if I see him with a group of
women or I see him with a group of kids
I'm calling it calling it out
loud
hate it hate it hate it hate it I hate
this for you I hate this for everybody I
hate this for her I hate this for him I
hate this for everybody I hate it I'll
say this to you
listening if you are in a relationship
whether you're close friends you're in a
romantic relationship with somebody who
is a sexual predator and you're making
excuses for
them you
are um not encouraging but allowing
their behavior your leaving the third
and fourth and fifth and sixth time it
won't happen again it won't happen again
it won't happen again you are part of
the
problem nothing changes until we
change and yes I recognize this blows up
everything you didn't blow it up the
sexual predator in your life did all
you're doing now is acknowledging the
explosion of
everything but as a community as a guy
with a wife as a guy with a little
daughter I want us all like my buddy
Sean man he's he's we've had some some
conversations about the sexual predator
stuff I didn't even know was out
there that kind of crap stops when we
stop
it
period
period we'll be right
back hey what's up Dr John delone here
check it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the Great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're going to be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
you're going to learn the choices you
can make day by day to create a more
peaceful joyful less chronically
stressed non-anxious life plus when you
you pre-order my book I want to give you
something to help you today that's why
you'll instantly get my newest talk
smoke fire and freedom that I gave to
several thousand folks a few months ago
where I break down the misunderstandings
and myths we believe about anxiety how
to reclaim your freedom and how to build
a non-anxious life so pre-order building
a non-anxious life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney
doc all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show it was a hard one man there
was a hard one um couple of calls I'm
GNA have to go just go sit and stare at
a wall for a little bit uh or I could
call a friend like I tell you guys to do
all the time um as we wrap up today's
show we thought we'd go back so around
the office um this is like known just
throughout the whole company as Kelly's
theme song just for her life and um so I
thought it would share it with you it's
a song by the band lit and the song's
called My Own Worst Enemy and it goes
like this this is a favorite song that
she sings a lot like it's it's very
autobo
graphical can we forget about the things
I said when I was drunk I didn't mean to
call you that I can't remember what was
said or what you threw at me please tell
me please tell me why my car is in the
front yard I'm sleeping with my clothes
on I came in through the window last
night and you're gone it's no surprise
I'm My Own Worst
[Music]
Enemy your poetry is so good Kelly and
I'm glad you got royalties off writing
this song that's good no I wish I
wouldn't be sitting
here I love you guys bye stay in
school